nos gustaría que fuera un espacio seguro
para todos son libres de decir lo que
quieren lo que sienten se trata de una
sesión especial de prevención para este
grupo del último año en el orden del día
el ciberacoso y la porno divulgación un
delito más conocido bajo el término
inglés sobre venes pero lo mejor es
conectarse en modo privado en las redes
sociales para evitar el ciberacoso es
importante saber que todas las
publicaciones fotos mensajes etcétera
pueden encontrarse en internet net mae
by chloe dos estudiantes de secundaria
están concientizando a sus compañeros y
se inspiran en su propia experiencia
buscaban mi perfil de instagram para
compartirlo y para acosar me tuve que
cambiarme el nombre
entré en pánico apague el teléfono y me
puse a llorar
maeva es cofundadora del colectivo
feminista stop fish a afiche en francés
postear en español es el acto de
publicar fotos de personas desnudas en
las redes sociales sin su consentimiento
durante el confinamiento el número de
cuentas de ficha que recogen y difunden
este tipo de contenidos se disparó y
nunca sabemos quién está detrás del
teléfono quién es la persona a la que
los suscribimos y entonces me encontré
con esto y me impactó las redes sociales
cambian las personas declaren un millón
aquí porque con el anonimato hay gente
que hacen cosas imperdonables y
anormales
hay mucha gente que amenaza a las
personas con editar sus rostros para
ponerlos en imágenes pornográficas etc
sin embargo no se trata de que las dos
jóvenes feministas hagan sentir
culpables a las víctimas
si envías fotos íntimas a tu pareja oa
otra persona es muy importante que no
pongas tu cara ni joyas ni collares ni
nada que pueda hacerte reconocible pero
eres libre de publicar lo que quieras
enviarlo a quien quieras es muy
importante que los dos con sientan pero
es su derecho y su asunto gracias
[Aplausos]
el colectivo esto fisa nació con un
objetivo cerrar las cuentas que divulgan
estos contenidos ilegales su arma
señalar en particular gracias a una
asociación con la plataforma net cat que
te escucha en español el servicio
estatal especializado en violencia
digital hay cientos y cientos de cuentas
que debemos señalar así que lo añado
para enviar una prueba así puedo hacer
capturas de pantalla de las fotos de
esta chica para enviarlas a net escuchan
snap chat no son receptivos no nos
responden en absoluto es la plataforma
de escucha la que cierra las cuentas un
trabajo de hormiga que se repite sin
cesar ya que cuando se cierra una cuenta
es muy fácil volver a abrir otra mae vas
contactada frecuentemente por nuevas
víctimas
sí hola
sí hola cómo estás estoy asumiendo esto
sola puede ayudar cuando se tiene el
apoyo de hermanos hermanas amigos
quiero que sepas que estoy aquí para
fijar también que con las otras chicas
siempre estaremos aquí para ti aunque a
veces por la noche sólo quiero dejar el
teléfono y parar no puedo
pienso que hay víctimas que esperan mi
mensaje mi consejo y eso es importante a
veces si es mentalmente complicado pasa
factura
aunque la divulgación de imágenes
sexualmente explícitas se castiga ahora
con dos años de prisión y una multa de
sesenta mil euros las condenas son muy
poco frecuentes
rachel flor pardo es la abogada del
colectivo stop fish a lamenta que las
plataformas se nieguen a revelar la
identidad de los usuarios señalados por
los tribunales
sigue habiendo dificultades para
cooperar con las distintas plataformas
en las que se distribuyen estos
contenidos estoy pensando en particular
en telegrama que es hasta donde yo sé la
plataforma que reunió las cuentas de
fichas más importantes y que hoy no está
colaborando en absoluto con la justicia
otra dificultad es la formación de todos
los policías en materia digital
en este sentido formemos a los
investigadores y los policías que son
las primeras personas con las que tendrá
que tratar una chica o un chico que
quiera presentar una denuncia por estos
peritos sobre lo que son estos dos
lugares donde cada día se cometen más
delitos
la facción que no debía
desde enero funciona un servicio de
fiscalía digital especializado su
objetivo dar una respuesta judicial más
rápida a las víctimas y representar a la
justicia francesa en su pulso con las
plataformas de mensajería